ahead of the start of apex legends
legacy respawn released a new trailer
that gave us the backstory of kyrie
imahara an upcoming playable character
who will be added in the new season
and sticking to the themes of legacy
there are a few references in the
trailer to the rest of the titanfall
universe let's dive into it
let's start at the very beginning with
the opening shot of the trailer as kyrie
looks down at some discarded scrap where
a destroyed moon can be seen in the
background
this is where she finds the remains of
her father viper as well as the
remaining pieces of his titan
the planet is typhon we can tell because
typhon is where viper died in titanfall
2
and typhon has a destroyed moon orthros
orthros is important because it is where
the imc
first tested their fold weapon a planet
killer typhon is where the weapon is
located at the end of titanfall 2.
protagonist jack cooper would sabotage
the fold weapon
so when the imc fired it again it
backfired destroying itself
and typhon throughout the trailer we got
several close-up shots of viper's helmet
we did get to see the helmet in
titanfall 2 but not nearly as close as
this
viper don's a helmet that looks very
similar to the titanfall 2 pilots that
wield a pulse blade
though it's not exactly the same seeing
cuban blisk is a bit of an obvious
reference but one worth calling out
blisk once led an elite group of titan
pilots called the apex predators this
mercenary group always worked for the
highest bidder and you could only be
invited
into the group via special invitation
you can see vipers invite later in this
trailer during the first flashback
and speaking of blisk did you know that
he's voiced by jb blanc who also voices
caustic and apex legends
that's the problem with most pilots i
makes you blind i don't relish the title
i relish the kill when we flash back to
kyrie as a child we first see them in a
room with several paintings on the wall
one of which is of a valkyrie we learn
later in this trailer that valkyrie is
kyrie's call sign
and speaking of that call sign it marks
the seventh character in apex legends
who takes inspiration from their own
name
for their nickname valkyrie is just val
plus kyrie
the others are bluffhunder aka
bloodhound makoa gibraltar
aka gibraltar pathfinder aka pathfinder
octavio silva aka octane loba andrade
aka loba and ramya perek aka rampart
when we flash back to the present kyrie
mentions that she's a pilot which bliss
scoffs at
best pilot money can buy violet
if you haven't played titanfall or
titanfall 2 then you may not understand
that the word pilot is not used in the
same way in this universe as
ours in this universe a pilot
specifically describes someone who has
been specially trained to not only use
titans but to also use advanced weapons
and technology in ways that
normal people can't as titanfall 2
protagonist jack cooper says
a pilot sees the world differently
currently only one other pilot has
joined the apex games and that's renee
blasey aka wraith who managed to become
a 10th generation pilot
meaning she's one of the best of the
best maybe that explains why a character
has such a high win rate
of course you can't be a pilot without a
titan in the second flashback we see
kyrie piloting her father's titan
especially modded north star
all north stars are designed for
long-range aerial combat but vipers has
been specially modified to fly faster
and longer
turning it into an actual aircraft you
may notice that the north star talks
back to kyrie
every different type of titan speaks
with a different voice
but you could customize your titan's os
voice in the original game with the
diversity of genders and nationalities
respawn changed that in titanfall 2 so
that each titan had an assigned voice
the scorch legion ronan and monarch
titans all have an os voiced by men
while the ion tone and north star are
voiced by women
north stars are voiced by nora j noon an
irish actor
as kyrie is flying her father's north
star we get a more clear view of the
planet though there's no way to confirm
it looks
surprisingly like typhon this could
explain why viper fights us with such
desperation in the final moments of his
boss battle in titanfall 2. he's
defending his home and family from us
we next see viper leaving for what's
presumably the battle of typhon which is
the opening chapter of titanfall 2's
second campaign
mission in the window behind viper you
can see viper's north star standing
alongside sloan's ion
and richter's tone you kill sloane
richter and viper and titanfall 2.
and speaking of viper's death strangely
enough kyrie blames blisk for her father
dying
you'd think she would blame jack cooper
considering he is the one who pulled the
trigger and ended viper
but perhaps this is a hint that there is
more to this story blisk's decision to
not say whether viper died or was
murdered certainly seems to say so
and let's end with what's likely the
most obvious reference the person
helping kyrie transform her father's
north star into a personal jet pack is
none other than rampart in a loading
screen you could unlock during apex
legend season 6
you can see the north star in rampart's
garage teasing the upcoming story
development
and that's all the references that we
found in the new trailer did we miss
anything
let us know in the comments be sure to
like the video and subscribe to the
channel for more apex legends content
like this
if you're itching for more information
on the new season we already have a
video up that details
all the new stuff that we know is coming
apex legends legacy which is scheduled
to begin
may 4th
you